ich sah eine beule in seiner boxer hallo
mein name ist luca meine haare sind
gerade so scheiße dass ich eine käppi
und eine kapuze auf habe auf jeden fall
sehr wahrscheinlich schon im titel
eingeblendet was wir heute machen werden
und zwar mit sex ich lese mir heute eine
perverse fanfiction durch hier eine
kleine fan fiction von mir thema seht
ihr ja mit titel alles hier ist frei
erfunden gay sex
das könnte spannend werden weil es
übrigens nicht ganz genau wissen sollte
was eine fan fiction ist das ist einfach
von irgendwelchen internet usern ein
kleines buch sage ich mache eine kleine
geschichte aufgeschrieben von
irgendwelchen personen aus irgendwelchen
serien film oder halt von youtube und in
dem fall jetzt halt von mir aber ich
würde sagen ich glaube gar nicht mehr
lange rum und wir stürzen uns direkt
rein also nur der anfang eines kommt mal
ein bisschen runter lukas provieh also
meine sicht jetzt quasi ich stand
vorsichtig aus meinem bett auf denn
meinen freunden max allein schon die
sache dass max und ich hier zusammen
sind in meinen freunden max schlief
neben mir er sei so süß aus wenn er
schlief ich küsste ihn auf seine wange
er lächelte ich machte uns frühstück
bacon mit bacon mit ei ist das aller
geilste was man zum frühstück essen kann
ich denke den tisch und stellte das eben
zubereitete auf ihnen ich wollte max
wecken doch auf einmal spürte ich starke
arme um meine hüfte ich wusste sowieso
dass es mein freund war da fing an mich
am hals zu küssen saugte an meinem hals
und hinterließ dort einen knutschfleck
ich töte leicht auf und drehte mich um
nabeg gut geschlafen fragte ich erwarte
dieses bevor ich anfing ihn
leidenschaftlich zu küssen ich biss ihm
leicht auf seine unterlippe um nach
einlass zu bitten
es begann ein wilder zum kampf weder max
noch ich sind schwul aber okay ich würde
sagen wir dieses mal weiter er ließ von
mir ab nahm meine hand und schmiss mich
auf mein bett
max ich bin da doch gerade erst
aufgestanden max stand oberkörper frei
da so dass ich seinen perfekten körper
sehen konnte ich dann auf und küste
seien halt worauf er leicht es ist
keuchen ich war immer weiter runter
küste sein schlüsselbein eine brustwarze
worauf er leise stöhnte daraufhin kam
ich habe auch an und legte über jeden
der bau losgehen dann seine frau linie
er kaufte und ich musste gehen
ich glaube ich muss das ganze mal ein
bisschen ernster dem weil das hier ist
ja echt in einer gewissen form kunst ich
machte mich an den bund seiner
jogginghose zu schaffen ich zog sie
runter und schmiss ihn die letzte ecke
des frachters ich sah eine beule in
seiner boxer
[Musik]
ich sah eine beule in seiner boxershorts
er wurde roth ich lächelte ich vor ihm
über sein hartes glied und seine
unterhose aus ein geiler schwarz was so
lang und so gailer schwachen lang und
dick worauf ich ebenfalls eine erektion
bekam ich freute mich riesig über das
was gleich geschehen würde
naja also ein typischer luca würde
eigentlich das frühstück bevorzugen
glaube ich ich umschlungen sein glied
mit meiner hand fuhr auf und abwärts
woraufhin er stöhnte und sich in meinen
haaren fest krallte grinsend legte ich
an seiner eichel ein lauter stimme
friday freunde denn das nicht mehr durch
lesen es wäre schon hart genug wenn das
einfach irgendein text war wildfremde
leute wir haben das ist über max und
mich aber gut wie lesen wir weiterhin
sind elektrisch an seiner reichen ein
lauter stimme entfleucht sie ihm ich
nahm ihn ganz in den mobilen max stöhnte
immer lauter als ich bemerkte wie er
sich in meinem mund ergoss
optisch alles
ihn an
jetzt steht hier max sowie also die sich
quasi aus max augen glücklich öffnete
ich seine kondome
ökomode holte eine tube gleitgel heraus
luca grinste mich mit seinem
wunderschönen lächeln danke ich küsste
ihn am ganzen körper legte seine frau
linie entlang er stöhnte leise ich zog
ihm seine boxershorts aus und schon
sprang er sein langer dicker beschnitten
kindes entgegen freunde
wer schreibt denn so was ich bekam mein
lächeln nicht mehr auf meinem gesicht
als ich sein bestes stück massierte
keuchte er auf max
[Gelächter]
jetzt sind wir wieder bei lukas nicht
angekommen also ich befall in einem
geilen freund jetzt gnädig auf mein bett
sonst würdest du es noch bereuen brav
tat er das was ich wollte ich zu beiden
pobacken auseinander und steckte mein
kopf zwischen diese effekte wie wild an
seinem arschloch er stöhnte laut degas
was ist das ich nahm mir die tube
gleitgel schmierte etwas auf sein enges
loch etwas auf meinen finger bist du dir
sicher dass du das willst fragte ich mag
es ja fick mich mit deinem geilen
schwanz in vielen ecken des schlosses
ein büfett
das ist ja unfassbar was ihre sachen
schreibt also ok weiter geht's ich
fühlte meinen finger ein er stöhnte ein
zweiter finger kamen hinzu und ein
dritter er stöhnte immer lauter meine
erektion wurde immer härter nochmals
griffig zur trouper und verteilte
großzügig das farblose gel auf dem penis
ich küsste seinen rücken hinterließ
zahlreiche knutsch flecken erst führte
ich nur meine eiche einen dann den rest
max stöhnte laut ohne rücksicht auf
verluste ich wurde immer schneller er
stimmte laut massierte seinen penis im
rhythmus meiner harten stöße ok freunde
freunde
das also natürlich in einer gewissen
form ist es gerade echt lustig dass
durchzulesen
aber das ist auch hat komisch max
krallte sich in meine matratze und zog
sich zusammen er spritzt alles auf mein
bett ungefähr sechs stößen später kam
auch ich und er goss mich in ihm zog ihn
raus max und ich grinsen um die wette
liegt nur zum kuscheln uns aneinander
und stiegen ein
wir sind gerade ist aufgewacht und was
ist mit dem verdammten frühstück das was
jetzt hier auch vom video meine damen
und herren ich wollte mir einfach mal an
einem fan fiction durchlesen
es geht anscheinend noch weiter ich
glaube dieses video hier wird safe ab 18
seien von youtube ich habe zwar nichts
verbotenes see gezeigt oder so aber
allein wegen der wortwahl
wenn ihr allerdings trotzdem wollte dass
ich eventuell den nächsten teil dieser
fanfiction einen nächsten video lese
dann lasst ein like dar und bei ich weiß
nicht
1000 das schon viel aber dann sehe ich
halt dass sie das vielleicht feiert was
ich übrigens auch noch mal sagen wollte
war einfach ich habe euch lieb und das
sage ich viel zu selten glaube ich also
es gibt viele leute die mir sagen ja ich
liebe euch alle aber danke dass ihr da
seid und halt's maul